[Music]
in calorie counts portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between mountain dew in the uk and the
us
this is food wars
in the uk mountain dew comes in three
portion sizes firstly we have this 330
milliliter can then we have a 500
milliliter bottle then we have our
larger size which is a one liter bottle
in the us mountain dew comes in six
portion sizes the smallest is this 7.5
ounce mini can then we have our standard
12 ounce can then a 16 ounce or one
pint can then when we go to bottles we
have a 16.9 or 500 milliliter bottle
jump up to the 20 ounce bottle and our
largest size the two liter bottle
as you can see i don't currently have a
one liter bottle as it was surprisingly
hard to track down i finally thought i'd
found some on amazon that ordered a six
pack then this showed up
they helpfully sent me 12 500 milliliter
bottles which is the same as six times
one liter however not really what we
were going for thanks guys ha our
largest size is double the size of the
uk's and we don't even stop there in the
u.s our largest single mountain dew item
is this
24 pack of 12 ounce cans that's
8.52 liters of mountain dew or 2.25
gallons it's a little unclear what our
largest single item is on the uk website
there is a multi-pack listed but it
doesn't say how many cans are in one and
i also couldn't find one anywhere so i
called brittvik who manufactured mounted
you here in the uk on behalf of pepsico
and an employee for them told me that
the multi-pack actually doesn't exist
the largest item that the company had on
their own records that they produce is
this
[Music]
a 24 pack of cans however this is
technically marketed at retailers rather
than consumers as you can see by the
fact that they have prices on the cans
we don't usually count wholesale on the
show so technically a one liter bottle
is our largest size if you can find one
that makes the us's largest item 752
larger than the uk's it's also worth
pointing out the difference in price
between mountain dew and the two
countries sugary sodas in the uk get hit
with a sugar tax which raises their
price in an effort to stop people from
drinking them if you buy a 500
milliliter mountain dew from a
sainsbury's in the uk for example it
will cost you one pound 25 pence which
was around 1.69 at the time of recording
this nice the closest thing to that
price point in the us is this two liter
coordinate target this is listed as 1.98
you must be joking this isn't even two
dollars look at this that is alarmingly
cheap
for every milliliter in the uk bottle
you're paying 0.338 cents every
milliliter of this 2 liter costs 0.0995
cents
at 70
cheaper than the uk price hang on don't
you feel like when you go to like a
bodega or something this is like a
dollar so not only is mountain dew super
cheap but then when you get it like at a
like a sandwich shop or something you're
getting gouged
here are all the mountain dew products
in the uk that you won't find in the us
here are all the mountain dew products
you can find in the u.s you will not
find in the uk
show this video to the paramedics we can
actually only get three mountain dew
products in the uk one of which i
couldn't even find today i guess you
could sort of call our standard mountain
dew in the uk an exclusive because here
it's marketed as mountain dew citrus
blast while in the us it's just mountain
view this also comes in a diet version
which is the thing i couldn't find today
the only other thing we can get in the
uk is this which is a sodastream
mountain dew syrup for those of you who
don't know sodastream is a device which
lets you carbonate your own drinks at
home pepsico owns both mountain dew and
sodastream so i guess it made sense for
them to just mash their products
together now i love sparkling water so i
actually own my own soda stream
and we can use it to make our own
mountain dew take one of your little
sodastream water bottles fill it with
water
screw it into the machine once it's nice
and secure press the magic button
sodastream if you want to sponsor me in
order to find me
and bang your fizzy water
nice splash of the syrup
that is a uh a strange color on that i
don't think that's what i was expecting
it to look like so i think our homemade
stuff actually might look slightly more
appealing you could kind of pass this
off as more of a fruity soda rather than
mountain dew from the bottle which is a
bit more translucent just a bit kind of
more pallid and weak and not really sure
what's going on
that's actually not bad
that's actually not bad it's quite a
mild flavor it's not actually
aggressively sweet also not too bubbly i
guess you have a bit more control over
the bubble level with the sodastream
despite the difference in the color they
actually taste really similar that's
actually a pretty accurate recreation
jesus christ that's one of the sweetest
things
i've ever tasted in my entire life
god it's like crammed more sugar than
there is space into that ah
okay i'm guaranteeing julie i'm going to
throw up in the middle of this in the
u.s we have something you can't get in
the uk as mountain dew zero sugar
apparently even diet mountain dew still
has some sugar in it i'm not surprised
at all let's see we got
regular
zero sugar well that's like really close
i don't mean to do the
mountain dew zero sugar commercial here
but it tastes exactly like regular
mountain dew
mountain dew frostbite i have no clue
what this is
oh that's terrible
i don't even know what that is is this
is a novella classic
i'm not playing i love mountain dew code
red it tastes like what's that drink
that you give kids when they want
alcohol
you get guys shirley temple
right what is that that's just sprite
and cherry grenadine right that's
exactly what this tastes like oh man
it's back baby mountain dew snapped it's
the gingerbread mountain dew it still
even has like christmas [ __ ] on it so
it's it smells just like gingerbread
cookies
it's good it's really good mountain dew
voltage do charge with raspberry such as
flavor and ginseng it says charged guys
look at this is a windex
yeah it has like a melted popsicle
flavor it's like a really strong flavor
is mountain dew spark
do with a blast of raspberry lemonade
okay
i've already hit a wall
oh god
it's like if you
tasked a child
to make kool-aid
it's i can't believe how strong this
stuff is mountain dew major melon
watermelon mountain dew look what's on
here look what they put on here do you
see this look look at the nightmare
that's on here oh it smells exactly like
a jolly rancher i like jolly ranchers
but in liquid form
no
oh this is really bad
it's like the most artificial tasting
thing we've had so far to save you from
getting too bored in this section joe
was kind enough to send me some mountain
dew from america as well as some
mountain dew code red let's do a little
side by side of british and american
mountain views getting a rare taste of
yellow five in the uk chin chin
whoa
what was that
you know in the film limitless when he
takes that pill and it just like
completely rewires his brain i think
that's what yellow five now does to
british people i've had like two sips of
this and i feel like i could fight god
now that i've tried the american version
the british version kind of just tastes
like sadness there's basically no flavor
to it other than sugar whereas at least
i think with this you get obviously a
lot of sugar but then there's a bit more
citrus as well this has even more
illegal food colorings in it we have red
40 and blue one which again hard to come
by in the uk
okay
i think i actually might just prefer
classic american mountain dew this one
felt like a religious experience whereas
this one just felt okay so i'll stick to
the classic g for now that wasn't enough
we also have a range of kickstart
mountain dews these are cans of dew
mixed with fruit juice and caffeine
imagine that caffeine black cherry
now that it said juice in there i really
taste the juice here ooh and
electrolytes it's like gatorade fruit
punch
love fruit punch
oh yeah that's very bad full disclosure
pineapple orange mango i had to get a
case of these just to get the one for
the video so i've been working on these
all week
this one's pretty good
oh man caffeine meter is just exploding
orange citrus
yeah it's not bad grape
that's like the grapeiest tasting grape
thing yeah the flavors aren't as harsh
because i cut it with the cut with juice
so yeah i kind of like the kickstarts is
that everything cause i'm getting a bit
bored over here i might just go and make
a cup of tea
sorry harry we have even more options we
have a mountain dew amp energy drink
more caffeine i'm assuming this is the
original you can also get it in cherry
blast
oh man that's really weird
whoa
that wasn't enough we also have mountain
dew energy why what was this
oh jesus they even broke oh my god look
they even broke it down on here two cups
of coffee
five percent juice no added sugar zinc
zinc
what's zinc got to do with anything
before i know the cans made of zinc oh
here it goes zinc helps support immune
function i mean i feel like i'm going to
drink this and like try and run through
a brick wall how would that do it for my
health citrulline and caffeine in
combination have been shown to help
improve attention
can't
get out of my face with this on here
let's do this uh orange breeze orange
breeze right this is a nice breeze of
orange
moments before you
tackle a stranger bite into their neck
for sustenance
oh that's really bad i don't think so
they shouldn't even have it like here
they should just have like a capri sun
like two whole streams bite into it like
teen wolf and drink it that way is that
possible to do that pomegranate
blueburst
this is driving me out of my mind i've
never had a pomegranate taste like that
and if i did i would spit it out ah
strawberry melon spark
[Music]
no melon drinks are bad peach mango don
the don a new dawn is here
[Music]
my vision is starting to blur tropical
sunrise
they've somehow bottled energy
like licking a nine volt
the last exclusive
mountain dew product we're gonna cover
before i go totally blind
is mountain dew game fuel it's a first
beverage quote designed just for gamers
for real hey sitting for 12 hours at a
time doing literally nothing staring at
a flashing screen drink this your
muscles won't atrophy as fast i'm not
quite sure what's in here to make it
better for gaming but the flavors they
have is cherry burst berry blast
original tropical strike and orange
storm let's take out the flavors and go
through those words one more time burst
blast strike storm stupid
you know so it's not as strong as the
energy drinks the charged berry blast
charge berry blast oh
man like pulling a tab out of a grenade
you know i'm surprised these aren't as
harsh as the energy drinks feeling i'm
feeling myself getting ready to game
julie getting ready to do some gaming
i'm gonna have to whoop some candy crush
ass
this one is the charge tropical strike
this one's not the bed full disclosure i
thought these were gonna hands down be
the worst i still don't like them but oh
charge cherry burst burst them with
cherry
here's the issue are they gonna make me
a better gamer so in one way to find out
i'm gonna play an extreme game that's
right let's do today's wordle i'm gonna
take a sip and then put in a five letter
word an extreme five letter word
skate
board
there you go this game feels not helping
taste oh wait not e though
okay blank a s t blank let's do cast
okay i think it'd be nasty n-a-s-t-y
all right wordle here we go is nasty yet
[Music]
that's right so what have we learned
uh me nothing carry on don't let me
interrupt
if that wasn't enough mountain dew
recently partnered with the boston beer
company to create hard mountain dew a
boozy spike seltzer version of mountain
dew and it comes in four flavors
original mountain dew baja blast oh god
black cherry and watermelon you're
asking joe where is that once do you get
drunk well i'm in california and it
currently is only available in the
united states in tennessee iowa and
florida of course it's in florida
joe i think we're going to need the lab
coats for this one
let's do it there's a fun faq on the uk
mountain dew website explaining why the
american version of the product isn't
sold here citing eu regulations there
are some pretty major differences
between the two some of which are
potentially harmful the us sweetens its
mountain dew with high fructose corn
syrup instead of sugar while it's not
necessarily any worse for you it
provides an even sweeter taste with a
slightly more chemical flavor the u.s
also flavors it's due with orange juice
which isn't specifically listed in the
uk ingredients one thing to look out for
in the u.s is sodium benzene this is a
sodium salt which food producers use as
a preservative on its own it's harmless
but when it's mixed with certain acids
like aerothobic or ascorbic acid it can
form benzene
benzene is a known carcinogen linked to
causing cancer in factory workers who've
been exposed to it the good news is u.s
mountain dew also contains calcium
disodium edta aka calcium disodium
ethylenediamine tetra acetate
this can't be spelled right terra
acetate look there's two a's next to
each other in that word with the
exception of aardvark i've never seen
two ways next to each other and that's
how that word starts this is a flavor
enhancer but it actually helps mitigate
the formation of benzene fantastic they
added poison chemicals into it then they
just add more chemicals to stop it from
being so poisonous studies have shown
that it collates the metallic ions that
catalyze hydroxyl radical formation it's
a complicated way of saying that it
removes the fuel from the fire
talk about teeth for a second because
mountain dew is pretty bad for your
teeth
when a man sued pepsico in 2009 he
alleged that he found a mouse in his can
of mountain dew but experts called in by
pepsico said that couldn't have been
true because mountain dew would have
dissolved the mouse into a jelly-like
substance
oh
oh my god if it is strong enough to
dissolve an entire mouse
you can imagine the effect mountain dew
has in the enamel of your teeth but
why is this happening it comes down to
two things sugar and acid tooth enamel
will start to erode if your mouth's ph
level drops below 5.5 mountain dew has a
ph of around 3.3 which is acidic but
actually on the better end of the
spectrum as far as sodas are concerned
sugar itself has a neutral ph so why
does it aid tooth decay our mouths play
host to a range of bacteria they're
usually harmless and can even be helpful
by fighting things like gingivitis
however they also love sugar and when
they eat it they produce acid bacteria
like streptococcus mutans will
metabolize sugar into lactic acid which
will then erode your teeth the more
sugar in a soda the more food these
bacteria have and the more acid they'll
produce so sugar isn't causing it per se
but it is aiding tooth decay acids
commonly used in soda include citric
acid and phosphoric acid firstly these
acids will lower the ph of your soda and
contribute to regular erosion but
they're also examples of polybasic acids
these bind to the calcium in our teeth
and cause us to lose enamel through
dissolution it's kind of like how you
can use acid to dissolve rust on a
metallic object all in all while
mountain dew might not have one of the
lowest ph's when compared to other sodas
its sugar content combined with its
other ingredients means that it is one
of the worst for your teeth a 2004 study
placed it as the second worst offender
for the dissolution of tooth enamel
second only to sprite really sprites
worse
and the bad news is the sugar-free
versions of sodas don't seem to be any
less harmful the replacement sweeteners
have the same effect on the bacteria in
your teeth if you're worried about your
teeth it's better to drink a soda
quickly than it is to continuously sip
it and prolong the exposure or you know
you could just stop drinking soda
interestingly the uk version actually
has one more gram of sugar when compared
to the american version but our mountain
dew is slightly more calorific and has
doubled the sodium of the uk version the
bottles contain 132 and 130 percent of
your daily sugar allowance respectively
let's find out what that looks like
[Music]
wait this is for hub how big of a thing
no way yeah oh my god
that's 50. we're not done yet
that's an appalling amount of sugar
i'm still gonna drink it another thing
worth pointing out is the caffeine
content of your mountain dew in the uk
many supermarkets will actually list
mountain dew as mountain dew energy this
is because we have stricter rules in the
uk about what does and doesn't count as
an energy drink in the uk sugar is a
major factor in deciding whether or not
something is an energy drink as opposed
to just caffeine mountain dew doesn't
actually disclose its caffeine content
in the uk all i could find was this
twitter reply from 2018 where they said
it used to be an energy drink but then
they reformulated it and now it has a
similar amount of caffeine to pepsi they
claim this is less than half the
caffeine content of a cup of coffee
regular mountain dew contains 72
milligrams of caffeine per 16 ounces
there's around 92 milligrams of caffeine
in the same amount of kickstart almost
one and a half espressos worth of
caffeine moving up mountain dew amp
original and cherry contain 142 and 160
milligrams of caffeine per 16 ounces
more than a double espresso
the worst defender is mountain dew
energy one of these cans contains 180
milligrams of caffeine per 16 ounces
which is basically a triple espresso for
reference the fda recommends that the
average healthy adult shouldn't consume
more than 400 milligrams of caffeine per
day that's just over two of those
mountain dew energies it's around the
1200 milligram mark where you're
actually putting yourself in danger
according to the fda ingesting 1200
milligrams of caffeine and you may
experience seizures or put yourself at
risk of cardiac arrhythmia so please do
not drink more than six of these at one
time the good news is that the lethal
dose of caffeine is around five grams so
to actually overdose on mountain dew you
need to chug 28 of the mountain dew
energies in pretty quick succession what
a way to go
i can't stop drinking it i'm slightly
concerned